JUSTINE: So it's not been a very good uh
time for apple products in the Ezarik household
Jenna got her macbook stolen
JENNA: ugh
your phone was it did you actually
oh
Oh oh my gosh
JUSTINE: shattered
ED: cut your head
JUSTINE: I know
So I was holding Matty and I was trying to get up on the elevator
and as I like put the key
to the door
Matty pulled really really hard
My phone was in my hand and it just fell just like this
face down
Jen you wanna come here and talk about something real quick
Poor Jenna got her computer stolen and we're not really sure how it happened
You made a video about it too
but we're not sure if it was like left in the hotel
but there was no possible way that she would've left that room
like without your computer JENNA: No it's my baby
JUSTINE: I know
JENNA: Thats like if I left Matty in a hotel room like I wouldn't do that
JUSTINE: no no no
JENNA: no no no
JUSTINE: I even done a last sweep of it
And now I have a shattered phone
JENNA: Look how cute Matty is though
JUSTINE: I mean I guess the Apple store is still open
so
JENNA: Go to third street
JUSTINE: Who who wants to go to owww
ED: Awww
JENNA: Thats a big shatter it's not even like a
JUSTINE: No no it's not yeah I can't I can't use my phone
Well I just wanted to say hi
and um bye and
Whats that? Whats that your? You got it really quick
ED: I got it real quick
JENNA: You guys my puzzle came in the mail
JUSTINE: What are you looking at Matt?
MATT: I'm just looking at what it looks like
JUSTINE: I got a new lens and Matts over there like
creeping it like hold on don't move
I'm gonna flip my camera around
This is what Matts doing
JENNA: *laughs* MATT: *laughs*
MATT: WELL TURN AROUND
JENNA: Well okay sorry
JUSTNE: I like it a lot
Oh my god it says beauty boy! *laughs*
MATT: *laughs*
JUSTINE: I thought it said built by
and I was like wait
that says beauty boy *giggles*
ED: Some white stuff on the hard buttons.
MATT: Wait you didn't get a Nadeshot scuff controller
This is the controller guys
JUSTNE: looks good
MATT: Doesn't that look great
JUSTINE: It does look nice
MATT: the back
What's wrong?
Oh
There's no panel
I win with fewer buttons
JUSTINE: mmm hmm
ED: This day seems so long but I woke up at like five
and I JENNA: PM?
JUSTINE: I gotta go to the apple s- OH MY GOD LOOK
THERE'S A HOLE IN IT
Can you see it on the screen?
Careful don't cut yourself it's super sharp
There's a hole in my phone
A screw
MATT: I guarantee I'll hit the hole on this door first try
JENNA: Your gonna scare Matty
ED: first try
JUSTNE: That was absolutely awful
Siri make me a genius bar appointment
now
SIRI: Okay I set up your appointment for today
BEEP
JUSTINE: I mean
Nothing I didn't swear
There's another now there's an apple support app?
ED: hmm?
JUSTINE: There's an apple support app
ED: Okay didn't know about that
JUSTINE: Me either that's new because I couldn't make
an appointment off of the apple store where I usually do it
This is crazy it's got
Oh my god!
It has all of
holy crap
ED: All the times you got support?
JUSTINE: No it has all of the items I currently have
have possible access to
Oh my gosh there's nothing
I'm so sad
What do? How do?
Well
That's it
I just wanted to share you with you guys
the sad news of what happened and
at least my dogs cute and
and I didn't get my computer stolen like Jenna
Well I'll keep you guys posted
But as of now I can't get a reservation
for like three days. Until Monday
That's crazy!
Okay bye
Oh my gosh it smells so lovely
It says interpretation because
because this definitely doesn't smell like a new mac
I don't think at all
but
If it is an interpretation
then it smells very very lovely
So for those of you that have never smelled a new